(slow bright music)
- When you start cave exploration,
you're jumping into an opening
under earth where nobody,
really nobody, was in before.
You're the first human
in this area,
and you look into time window.
We're talking millions of years actually
what you have right in front of you.
This is a fantastic feeling.
(slow cinematic music)
My name is UWE Rath,
and I'm a diving instructor;
and I'm living here 26 years
in the Dominican Republic.
My specialty is to explore caves.
When I started
I was not looking for caves;
I was looking for some
(mumbles) old Indian stuffs.
I found big cave entrances;
and of course, as a diving
instructor you are interested
what's going on here.
And this is when I started actually
to explore my first caves.
I was a pioneer in cave exploration.
(slow bright music)
The Dominican Republic
has right now more than 140 caves
we're still exploring;
and here in Bayahibe
we have a nice huge National Park.
And this National Park is like,
ah, Swiss cheese.
It has a huge amount of underwater caves.
When I do this today,
of course, you're looking
at a cave explorer
in a completely different way.
Maybe you find a different passage
or maybe you can connect
a whole bunch of caves.
You're always looking really
for small openings to find new stuff.
(slow bright music)
Diving in the open ocean,
when you have a small problem, you're way
out of the water is to going up.
In a cave, you have an
overhead environment,
you cannot go up.
When I go
in the ocean you have noises everywhere.
You can listen to the boat engines,
you can listen to noises under water.
When you go in a cave you
will listen to nothing—
just to your bubbles;
and this is for me one
of the most wonderful things on earth.
No noises at all.
Cave diving is my passion,
and still after 20 years I love it.
I love to teach people
to do cave diving in a safe way.
I'm 59 years old, so I
need somebody behind me
to do the same stuff
when I'm getting too old.
This is good
for me to see the young people
they are into
this nice, nice, nice
cave exploration thing.
I'm very happy they're asking still
the old guy how to do some stuff.